ما تبعنا يبدو ان قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي
تجاوزوا المعضله المجاريه نعم هذه المعضله
التي ارقت القاده الاوروبيين منذ ديسمبر
الماضي حيث رفض رئيس الوزراء المجري
فيكتور اوربان المصادقه على هذه المساعدات
التي كان يريد الاتحاد الاوروبي تقديمها
لاوكرانيا التي بحاجه الى هذه المساعدات
على حسب قول يعني قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي
لكن هذه المساعدات واجهت رفض اوربان الذي
يعني شكل جدلا واسعا بهذا الموقف اوربان
كان قد دفع ب يعني اسباب هذا الرفض هو ان
هذه المساعدات ستشكل عب اضافي على
الاقتصادات الاوروبيه التي تعاني من ازمات
متتاليه
وايضا اليه اعطاء هذه المساعدات كانت ليست
على يعني ما يريد هو ان تكون هو دفع بان
تكون هذه المساعدات مقدمه على شكل خارج
نطاق الميزانيه الاوروبيه اي على مدى اربع
سنوات اي لحتى حتى العام 27 وهي الميزانيه
التي اراد اعضاء الاتحاد ان تصرف
لاوكرانيا وهي تقدر ب 50 مليار يورو سيكون
33 مليار منها ب على شكل يعني ديون و
17% سب 10% منها عفوا ستكون مقدمه
كمساعدات اذا هو كان يريد ان يكون هنالك
يعني قرار سنوي وان تقدم من الاتحاد يعني
مبلغ او يقدم مبلغ بقيمه 18 مليار على ان
يتم مناقشه فيما اذا يعني تستحق اوكرانيا
او التزمت بعمليه توزيع هذه الاموال على
يعني بشكل يتوافق مع قوانين الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذه القضيه جوبهت بالرفض التام
من باقي اعضاء الاتحاد واعتبرت هي محاوله
للضغط على اوكرانيا وايضا على يعني وضع
الاتحاد الاوروبي في موضع ايضا غير لا
يتناسب مع موقف اعضاء الاتحاد في قضيه هذه
الحرب التي تعاني منها اوكرانيا وهي قد
تشكل اي تاخر المساعدات
لاوكرانيا قد تشكل ضغط كبير على الحكومه
الاوكرانيه التي تواجه العدوان الروسي
بحسب وجهه النظر الاوروبيه اذا هذا الامر
على ما يبدو حل باللحظات الاخيره
المعلومات التي تسربت يوم امس عن هذا
القضيه وكما تشير الزميله في القسم
الفرنسي وهي المتخصصه بشؤون الاوروبيه
كارولين دو كاماري حتى وقت متاخر من الليل
بعد ان رفض
اغباني يمهد لهذه الجلسه توجه بعض من
القاده الاوروبيين الى مقر اقامته في احد
الفنادق في بروكسل و وتمكنوا من التوصل
هذا الاتفاق اذا هذا الاتفاق يعني
كان صعب المنال لكنه في هذا الشكل يعد
انتصارا للقاده الاوروبيين هذا التقدم
ايضا تفاعلت معه كيف بطريقه ايجابيه من
خلال الرئيس الاوكراني الذي سارع في
التعبير عن تفاؤله في استمرار الدعم
الاوروبي وشكري للاتحاد الاوروبيين لعضاء
الاتحاد الاوروبي ال 27 وكذلك رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني عبر عن امتنانه وشدد
على ان هذه المساعدات هي مساعدات ضروريه
لبقاء الاقتصاد
الاوكراني كشكل في في هذه الازمه مقاوما
لكل الضغطات التي تسببت فيها هذه الحرب
لكن عمر يبدو ان اوربان لم يكن الوحيد
الذي يعتقد بان اوكرانيا تشكل خطرا على
الاقتصادات الاوروبيه وعلى القطاع الزراعي
بشكل خاص نعم هذه المساله بدت واضحه من
خلال الحراك الذي يقوم به المزارعون في
العديد من الدول الاوروبيه من بينها فرنسا
وحتى بلجيكا واسبانيا وكذلك يعني بولندا
هذه الموجه من الانتقادات ل الاتحاد
الاوروبي من خلال دعمه او تسهيل وصول
المنتوجات الاوكرانيه الى السوق الاوروبيه
سببت مشكله كبيره بالنسبه للمزارعين
الاوروبيين وهم يعترضون على مساله التكلفه
اي كلفه انتاج المحاصيل الاوكرانيه اقل
نسبه من كلفه انتاج المحاصيل هنا في
الاتحاد الاوروبي او في دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي مما يخلق منافسه غير عادله وهي
بالتالي تظر بمصالح المزارعين اوربان الذي
ي يعني يعد من القاده الشعبويين في اوروبا
استغل هذه الموجه من الغضب حتى انه يعني
قام بالذه هاب الى المزارعين الغاضبين
الذين يعني وصلوا حتى هذا اليوم امام مقر
الاتحاد للضغط على القاده المجتمعين كان
قد يعني عبر عن دعمه لهذه الموجه
الاحتجاجيه وهو يريد من خلال هذا الدعم ان
يقف الى جانب المزارعين الاوروبيين هو
ايضا يتهم بانه يحاول ان يستخدم هذه
الورقه اي ورقه الغضب الاوروبي والضغط من
اجل ايجاد حلول ضد المساعدات الاوروبيه
المقدمه لاوكرانيا والتي تؤثر على
الاقتصادات الاوروبيه بحد بحسب وصفه هو
يريد ان يستخدم هذه كورقه ضغط في
الانتخابات الاوروبيه المقبله وهو يعول
كثيرا على غضب الشارع
وخاصه الجانب ان صح التعبير المتطرف
اليمين المتطرف الذي يقف ايضا لاستغلال
هذه الموجه او غضب المزارعين اذا
المعلومات تشير بان هذا الاتفاق الذي تم
وان كان يعني اتفاق لا يتناسب مع متطلبات
اوبان هناك ايضا ربما تحصل على بعض
التطمينات في
مستقبل الديون لكن هنالك ايضا اخبار
معارضه لهذه او متعارضه مع هذا الخبر تشير
بان الاتحاد الاوروبي سيواصل مساله
العقوبات الاقتصاديه المفروضه على حكومه
اربان خاصه وان الاتحاد الاوروبي او قاده
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني تتهم هذه الحكومه
بعدم التوافق مع قوانين الاتحاد الاوروبي
لذلك هو لا يستحق تقديم هذه المساعدات
المستحقه لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي بطريقه
متساويه لكن على ما يبدو الطريق لازال
طويلا امام تحقيق كل مطالب هذا يعني ال
رئيس الوزراء المجري الشعبوي في هذه
المرحله يبدو ان القاده الاوروبيين تمكنوا
من تجريده من سلاح الضغط وهم فرضوا اراده
الاتحاد على المجر اشكرك عمار على كل هذه
التوضيحات